hi my name is aiden reese i'm eight
years old today
i'm adding two chefs to make my extreme
dish wish
hey aiden hi everybody i'm alexis
hello i'm claudette hello claudette
zepeda wilkins here from san diego
california executive chef
partner at el jardin restaurant i've
always been in restaurants but i didn't
know i wanted to be a chef until my son
was born
and i thought you know how could i tell
him to chase his dreams if i don't
pursue mine so
here we are so aiden if you were a
pirate out at sea
what would you eat i'd eat dead men's
fish stew
dead man's fish stew so what's in the
stew good question
some dead fish dead food
anything dead from the sea guts and
bones
and stuff yeah do you like seafood
well not really i like salmon
he doesn't like seafood which i find
problematic i don't eat meat
rice i like healthy food it's good for
your brain you know
use a little squid or maybe it could be
a jellyfish
i'll put it dead and he started
mentioning squid
i know he's not gonna like it i've never
had
squid before but it's worth a try i mean
right
there'd be dead bones from like actual
humans sure yeah
so like i'd say the school that's the
important part
it's got the most flavor i get it
i'm just gonna choose to omit that
entirely it's a little narcos
it went a little dark on us any
vegetables that you can find in the
ocean
well there's one vegetable which
they call seaweed i've never really
tried it
but it's worth a try so what normally
would a pirate
drink when he's having this dead man
stew
they would normally drink beer coca-cola
mixed together and maybe some root beer
like a root beer coke beer float yeah
i usually save the cherries for my mom's
that's mostly it okay do you think we
can make this dish come alive
it's worth a try
the one thing i have going for me is
that i've done this twice i feel like i
now know that if a kid says they want
something
it doesn't necessarily mean they want
something i am not going to make a stew
i am going to make pizza top it with
bechamel
cheese salmon salmon roe shrimp
i'm going to fry some squid add some
dill
and basil and then some real seaweed so
it's kind of a mix for him so hopefully
it'll be like a
seafood medley pizza so for my dish i'm
going to make a tomato bisque soup
i'm going to carve the skull the ribs
the toes
i think there's a pelvis in there too
somewhere out of potatoes
i am going to make seaweed jungle out of
fried basil for the drink it's
easy i'm going to make a fanta float
with orange sherbet and
two cherries on top for his moms
claudette i'm so excited to cook with
you or against you you're a chef and a
mom
you have so much going for you you're
making pizza so you win
but like i literally don't know what
kids like so let's see
i'm gonna saute the onions real quick
get them sweated down
this will be the base of the blood and
plasma soup
i'm just trying to get really
caramelized develop the sugars in the
onions
last i'll do the raw tomatoes since
they're going to leak out a lot of water
so i'm making a bechamel
which is one of the mother sauces and
you can make so many other sauces based
off professional
i feel like maybe it'll be a catalyst
for him to like us
yes you know this could be deaf boys
that's the easy part you say something
really gross and you're like yeah
this little burner is a little funky so
might be doing this again i can see
alexis is struggling with her burner so
i just give her mine and
she needs a constant heat and induction
gives you that have the reputation for
being the worst competitor claudette is
not only so talented but so nice this is
like not really a competition it's just
like getting to hang out with a friend
it's getting this kind of nice
nutty brown and then i'm gonna add the
milk nice fish
thank you if i had a pirate ship it
would be named the brown
carrot it would have like machine guns
and stuff like that
which pirates do not have now i'm going
to make
brains made out of tomatoes i scored the
tomato in hopes that when it starts to
break down it'll look like
decomposing brain let's see how this
cooks
i'm just gonna do a super super simple
salmon
which i'm gonna bake and then plate i
feel like i've learned my lesson about
being too heavy-handed spices so
i'm gonna try to tone it down okay let's
start making bones
right now i am working on the poor
dead guy's femur bone out of this potato
it looks really convincing so far leg
bone
or thigh bone oh i got to make toes
toenail huh huh okay i'm actually
feeling
pretty excited about something i just
ground up chips and i'm gonna
dip the squid in them and deep fry it so
it becomes kind of like a like a chicken
nugget so i think it might help
hide the squid it feels a little moist
are you going to bind it with it
something egg is going to slip right off
of it
all right i'm sure i should not be
talking to her about that
again this is why i never win i think a
lot of the times because i am a chef of
a restaurant
and i am a mentor to my cooks when i see
someone struggle
my instinct is like that like protector
mom with the claw that's really great
suggestion i'm gonna dip the squid
into the egg and then into the ground
chips before frying it
yeah he's totally good no that's not
chicken nuggets i mean you can tell that
it's not
chicken but it looks pretty cool and he
might actually like it
don't mean to toot your own horn but
toot toot but
it's pretty good now i'm just going to
blend it up to get the consistency of a
tomato piss
her brain is still intact well not mine
but that
one mine's been shot for years because
we're on a bit of a time constraint i'm
using
a pre-made pizza dough just rotating the
dough like this is a really easy way to
stretch it
you spin it in the air do it challenge
politely declined
i am going to put the bechamel on the
pizza
cheese lots of cheese god i'm really
cheating this one come on
every other bone off all right i'm only
doing one
fishbone i feel like he should be
honored to get one
that's incredible i'm gonna add my puss
heavy cream i feel like yours is gonna
be something we actually want to eat
i'm just going to brush that just with a
little oil just let me get a little
glossier i'm going to bake this
and then put the seafood toppings on
after after you smart
just babysitting
you look pretty proud of yourself i mean
i mean you are doing what you asked for
and i'm not
so that's usually what happens though
again that's parenting
i'm looking over at claudette station
and she's carving a skull
out of a potato and i have pizza i've
seen
more healthy looking skulls but i think
it'll do that's as good as you're gonna
get
good night did you say good night
let's go to sleep with the fishes do you
know what a rock fish is
a rock fish a rock fish is like um
a fish with a stinger that when it gets
scared
or mad it stings you
i just got an idea to
fry the basil seaweed and see if i can
get
almost like a anemone she's got pizza so
i gotta pull out all the stops oh
what is my vision some shrimp
just gonna flake some with santa he's
gonna hate this
aiden doesn't like seafood but i think
it could be fun to add some salmon
definitely an acquired taste but i just
want to add like a few
and they pop in his mouth he's like
freak out i think it's kind of
genius that alexis wants to make a pizza
because even if you
get it wrong on the drawing you're going
to give the kid
what he wants glaudet has made a
masterpiece she's done
exactly what aiden wanted and i haven't
i just
i'm not i'm not feeling great got my
teeth i got my rotten toe
joints skull i mean it's amazing that's
crazy
i was so focused on the pizza that i
completely forgot about the drink i'm
just gonna wing it though
i couldn't think of what else could be
purple and orange yeah she's like okay
purple orange
soda called today huh well let the best
moment win
yeah yeah let's go see what aiden thinks
so my pizza's done and you know i feel
pretty fine about it but
he asked for stew so i really just hope
he
actually wants pizza i am happy with the
way the dish turned out visually and i
think i think it tastes delicious i'm
extra and so is my plating
so i know he's gonna like it bring on
the dead man's stew
it looks like sushi with
chicken tenders with seaweed i got
everything i wanted
okay looks like a pizza oh
it is a pizza
[Music]
that's pretty good tastes like something
slimy kind of
like edible slime it's pretty good on to
this part
oh okay that is weird
i do not like that part so go ahead and
try the milkshake ah
finally it tastes like
all the kind of like sodas combined and
it's good
all right let's do it here we go
now that's what i call a stew this is
all the stuff i
needed i like how it looks like my
drawing oh
wow that is weird wanna try that first
what does that taste like root beer and
fanta mixed together
and it also has the cherries on top
they're for my mom's here
all right go ahead grab a spoon dig in
did not like it onto the seaweed
[Music]
mmm the seaweed's good not like normal
seaweed
and now for the rotten fish
it tastes like mango probably want to
keep that on the side looks like
a brain had to give me a brain
that tastes like tomato and i don't like
tomato
you know anything else yeah go ahead
have some more of the shake
okay aidan you just had two very
different dishes
which one do you like better the stew or
the pizza
hmm that's a hard decision but
that's like the pizza
[Music]
i told you it was a cheese it was a
cheese right alexis
because you won you get to keep the
drawing
thank you so much i mean what a drawing
this is really exciting this was such a
fun competition claudette was
amazing and honestly really helped me
out so couldn't have had this without
her
cuisine is not like a failure to me i
think failing is not trying
pizza cheese carbs always wins no matter
how slimy the
stuff on top is chefs thank you for
my dead man stew yarn
[Music]
you